hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir hier seht ist bereits im
titel eingeblendet meine damen und
herren wir spielen heute würdest du
lieber würdet ihr lieber würdest du
lieber geht es darum dass wir einmal
eine rote und eine blaue seite haben und
auf der roten seite steht eine sache und
auf der blauen seite steht eine sache
und wir müssen uns dann entscheiden was
wir lieber machen würden
als erstes haben wir beispielsweise
entweder ins jahr 1950 reisen oder ins
jahr 2050 reisen ich würde an der stelle
jetzt sagen da 1950 wer genau wissen was
da eigentlich schon war 2050 allerdings
noch zukunft ist sage ich definitiv ins
jahr 2050 reise und da bin ich auch mit
75 prozent ganz klar in der mehrheit
würdest du lieber einen hund oder eine
katze zu sein ich glaube das kommt so
auf den einzelnen an als ob man eher
eine katze oder hund mag ich würde ganz
klar lieber ein hund sein da sagen auch
62 prozent dass sie das er gerne sein
würden hier unten schreibt alex yao mgh
habe ich ja auch darum einen garten
würdest du lieber immer im spiel
verlieren oder allgemein das spiel nicht
spielen können
lieber immer verlieren macht er viel
mehr sinn wenn es einem spaß macht er
natürlich lieber verlieren also wieder
67 prozent klar in der mehrheit wir
versuchen jetzt mal immer in der
mehrheit zu sein
ja das ist eine ganz tolle challenge
luca möchte ich lieber vergessen werden
oder zwar in erinnerung bleiben
allerdings als schlechter mensch ich
finde diese what you're a sachen prägen
ein so richtig so die zeigen so richtig
was man für ein charakter ist eine
ewigkeit später
hey das ist ultra schwierig gerade auf
der einen seite möchte man nicht
vergessen werden also nie möchte man
glaube ich irgendwie von irgendwem
vergessen werden allerdings auf der
anderen seite wenn man nicht vergessen
wird dann bleibt man in erinnerung als
schlechter mensch also ich glaube habe
verstanden was ich gerade hier
vorgelesen habe ene mene meck und du
bist weg also rechte seite
ok schreibt auch der user hier würdest
du lieber einen schlechten ratschlag
geben oder einen schlechten ratschlag
erhalten
ich glaube ich möchte lieber einen
schlechten start schlag geben weil sonst
wäre es schlecht für mich da sind auch
klarer mehrheit mit 54 ok wasser ist
klar wir hatten vier prozent mehr
würdest du lieber alles zu wissen oder
alles zu haben
zu macht keinen sinn in beiden sätzen
ein paar sekunden später
das ist dumm sorry dass ich das so sage
aber wenn man alles weiß dann kann man
doch auch alles haben weil man halt
unendliches wissen hat stimmt also ich
würde sagen alles zu wissen ganz klar
wieso ist das zu eng -psych habe aus
versehen das falsche gedrückt ja du hast
du auch aus versehen aus versehen falsch
geschrieben wahrscheinlich sind deine
eltern nicht zufrieden mit ihr seht ihr
oben auch übrigens wieder werbe video
eingeblendet weil das ganze wieder mal
eine kooperation mit google play ist
also die haben ja gesagt weil von google
play luca lahti wieder irgendein spiel
das vermächtnis aus dem google place
darunter und spiels einfach das ist so
mega geil vier woche auf mehr solcher
videos habe wie ich die teilweise früher
auch einfach schon hochgeladen habe dann
finde jetzt die um eine abstimmung
eingeblendet da könnt ihr einfach mal
mit ja abstimmen wenn ihr da bock drauf
habe und wenn nicht dann halt mit nein
und schreibt ein anderer spieler die
kommentare weiß ich was ich beim ersten
mal vielleicht würdest du lieber ein
meter größer sein oder ein meter kleiner
boah
es ist das ist gemein ich bin ein meter
93 groß wenn ich ein meter größer wer
welche größte mann der welt wenn ich ein
netter kleiner wäre wäre ich einfach 93
cm groß ich würde trotzdem sagen größer
ein meter größer sein
genau 73 prozent sagen dass auch das ist
echt eine ultra geile frage gewesen
würdest du lieber der schlechteste
spieler eines gewinnerteams sein oder
der beste spieler eines verlierer teams
lieber der schlechteste spieler eines
verliererteam 2 wenzel verlierer team
ist aber alle wissen okay ich war der
allerbeste von denen dann kann man ja
wechseln wegen anderen vereinen wenn man
allerdings der schlechteste spieler vor
dem gewinnerteam ist dann ist man
einfach nur scheiße da stimme ich habe
keine ahnung habe ich glaube ich wäre
lieber der beste spieler als verlierer
team mit damit auch in der mehrheit
nächste frage mit der nase eines
elefanten geboren werden oder mit dem
hals einer giraffe
a
lieber mit der nase eines elefanten 44
ist eklig aber interessant in der tat an
der stelle würde ich jetzt sagen meine
damen und herren dass ich jetzt nur noch
eine weitere frage beantworten darf wenn
ich bei der vorherigen frage in der
mehrheit war und sonst werde ich dieses
video hier direkt beenden das heißt ich
sage jetzt schon mal just like da wenn
es euch gefallen hat dass zwei lifestyle
wenn ich das noch mal machen soll und
jetzt beantwortet die fragen würdest du
lieber zehn leben mit jeweils 100 jahren
leben oder ein leben mit 1000 jahre
nämlich würde zehn jedem mit ok ich bin
in der mehrheit das heißt ja auch noch
eine zweite frage beantworten deine
finger schon lange wieder eine beine
oder deine beine so lang wie deine
finger
ich würde sagen deine beine so lange
wieder eine
das was jetzt hier vom video das was
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemanden kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten mal einen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und benny
schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]